all week at this time we've been
featuring political podcasters joining
us now
is michael knowles he is the host of the
michael knowles show which you can find
on the daily wire mr knowles thanks for
joining us this morning
thank you for having me it's great to be
here how do you describe your podcast to
people
well the traditional distinction is that
we cover politics
and culture but i think increasingly
that distinction
is a little bit blurry certainly after
the presidency of
donald trump that that distinction is
quite blurry so
we we cover that angle but you know uh
russell kirk
had a an important observation which is
that
uh culture is downstream of religion we
often hear of andrew breitbart the
patron saint of hollywood conservatives
who says
that politics is downstream of culture
culture is downstream of religion
these questions are not so easily
separated cardinal manning famously said
that all human conflict is ultimately
theological and so we we like to go
everywhere from the headline all the way
down to the philosophical
and theological premises that that
undergird those issues
give an example of a headline you're
looking at in today's things that you
cover and what are the cultural
underpinnings there
oh well the clearest example probably is
this transgender
issue you saw the governor of arkansas
last night
did not do a very good job defending his
position on television
he tried to make the argument that it is
somehow conservative
to give little children cross-sex
hormones
and puberty blockers and so at the top
level you see the headline that there
are these
people and children specifically who
have confusion about their sex
and they boys feel like they're little
girls and girls feel like they're little
boys then there is a cultural issue here
of what this means how this relates to i
don't know
pride parades the broader lgbt movement
what the premises that undergird this
are you know for the
for for most of the history of the gay
rights movement we've been told people
are born this way
and you know if you're a boy and you're
born and you have attraction to other
boys then you know
society should be more tolerant of these
views but then immediately after that
we're told that
according to transgenderism there is no
such thing as biological sex and if
you're a boy you can actually become a
girl
so those are premises that contradict
one another and ultimately there's a
religious question here
which is what is the nature of man you
know the traditional view in the west
is that man is hylomorphic to use the
technical term
so we're body and soul and these are
inextricably linked as long as we're
here on earth
and my body has something to do with who
i am and so does my soul
according to the transgender movement
now our bodies have absolutely nothing
to do with who we are so
i can look like a man i can have an
adam's apple i can have a deep voice
i've got all the various appendages
but if on some deeper metaphysical level
i feel as though i'm a woman
then actually i am a woman i'm it's not
even
complicated i simply am a woman my body
has nothing to do with that
and that is an ancient heresy called
gnostic dualism
it's cropped up repeatedly over the
course of western civilization so
i think if you want to understand that
issue which is about as
sensational and and topical as they get
it it really helps to to see
all the layers all the way down so that
one can can have a more informed view on
it
when you talk about these kind of issues
what do you hear from
perhaps people who support you and do
you have an avenue to for those who
maybe disagree with you on these issues
and what are you hearing from them
well from what i i hear from people who
support me they
like having this extra context i think
they enjoy pursuing these issues down to
the bottom so that
you know despite all of the emotion and
all of the passion that that often
accompany these things
increasingly probably in our politics
one can
use their faculties of reason they can
really think through these things
and come to a decision on how they feel
about this
i i certainly do have an avenue to
people who disagree with me
i didn't realize i had such an avenue
but then i look at my inbox every day on
my email and
my twitter feed and uh typically what i
would hear from them is is a more
impassioned argument and i i
don't mean to caricature my political
opponents
but usually what what those criticisms
involve
are just some comment that you are a
racist or a bigot or a thisist or
that ist and i think that when when
our political opponents engage in that
kind of evidence-free invective
it's a good good bit of evidence that
you've won the argument michael knowles
joining us until 8 45 and if you want to
ask them questions 202 748-8001 for
republicans
202 748 000 for democrats and
independents 202 748 8002
you can text us too at 202-748-8003
how do you describe yourself politically
and what shapes
what how you believe politically i
suppose
my friends have sometimes described me
as slightly to the right of attila the
hun
but i think this is somewhat unfair
actually because i think that
the the right and the left first of all
there are terms that come out of the
french revolution
so they're at relatively modern terms in
politics
i don't know that they totally
correspond to the way that our politics
works right now and i think that there
are a lot of problems on the right
and so i wouldn't call myself a leftist
but there are a lot of issues on the
right
right now this is actually that the
topic of my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
it really takes more issue with the
right because i think that
conservatives self-described
conservatives have fallen for traps that
have been laid for them by political
correctness
or cancel culture or wokeness or use
whatever term you want
and so i think very often that they have
not succeeded in conserving very much of
anything and the the governor of
arkansas's performance last night on
television
arguing that that conservatives ought to
chemically castrate kids i think
it proves that very well so i i would
like there to be
uh not just this tense battle forever
where the the
left and the right hold their positions
and just yell at one another i would
like to bring that conversation
forward a little bit by taking the
leftist intellectuals
who have brought that side of the aisle
to where to where it is right now i want
to take them seriously i want to see if
they know something that perhaps
the conservatives have have unfairly
dismissed or overlooked
and i think they can i actually think
one of the conclusions i reach in my
in my book speechless is that while the
right likes to pride itself
on this idea that we understand free
speech
so much better than than the left does
and they're just snowflakes who hate
free speech
actually i think the left understands
free speech and censorship
far better than the right does and i
think that's how they've been able to
amass and wield political power so
effectively
through political correctness and now
its derivative canceled culture
one of those issues that have come up in
the last week or so is this uh major
league baseball decision considering
it's all-star game
this connects to georgia's voting laws
this is something that the president
referenced yesterday
at the white house i want to play a
little bit what he had to say about that
decision and then get your response to
the topic
i think the masters golf tournament
should be moved out of georgia
i think that's up to the masters
look
you know it is reassuring
to see that
for-profit operations and businesses
are speaking up about how
these new jim crow laws are just
antithetical to who we are there's
another side to it too
the other side to it too is when they in
fact move
out of georgia the people who need to
help the most
people who are making hourly wages
sometimes get hurt the most i think it's
a very tough decision for a corporation
to make
or a group to make but i respect them
when they make that judgment
and i support whatever judgment they
make but it's
the best way to deal with this is for
georgia and other states to smarten up
stop it stop it mr knowles the president
from yesterday what's your reaction
that's quite the change in tune because
just a few days ago
president biden was absolutely
encouraging
major league baseball to move the
all-star game out of georgia which has
led to an
ironic consequence mlb has now moved the
all-star game to colorado
in the name of racial justice and
voting rights but of course colorado is
a much
whiter place than georgia and colorado
has more restrictive voting laws than
georgia
even after this much-maligned voter bill
so that obviously backfired
people of georgia including georgia
democrats are furiously
furious at president biden and so now
he's trying to reverse course
and say hey hold on other sports please
don't move your
your games out of here the the issue
with joe biden and i i say this actually
with all due respect
is that i don't think joe biden has very
many beliefs of his own at all
i think he wakes up in the morning he
licks his index finger puts it in the
air
and figures out which way the wind is
blowing he he has been this way
for his entire political career so he he
will change his positions according to
the prevailing political winds and i
think he thought that he was
catching the zeitgeist he thought that
he was with his base
but then when the practical effects of
that came in 100 million dollars leaving
georgia because of mlb
he realizes that he's got a reverse
course right now it raises this question
of on issues such as the
woke corporations or immigration
or voter id the democratic party right
now all the way up to the leadership
are pursuing a very unpopular policy
the majority of americans want a border
that is secure the majority of americans
support voter id the democratic party
does not do that why are why do they not
do that and why do they get away with it
i think the reason is
that they have waged for the last 100
years or so
a war of position to use the term of the
radical theorist antonio gramsci they
have attained positions
of power and influence throughout the
culture
and as a result they are wielding that
power now so
we can talk until we're blue in the face
and the american people can respond to
survey after survey after survey and say
we oppose this sort of thing
but they they lack the political power
to to actually
effect those policies so i think that
probably you know they'll they'll
recalibrate a little bit in the
democratic party but they're probably
going to keep up the radicalism
our first call for you comes from new
jersey this is mitchell democrats life
for michael knowles
of the michael knowles show show
mitchell go ahead you're on with our
guest
good morning pedro good morning mr nulls
uh
i'm not familiar uh with uh uh
michael's show uh but just a couple of
comments on
what i basically hear from conservative
uh uh columnist and conservative talk
show hosts
is that uh there seems to seem to
gravitate
towards a lot of emotional wedge issues
you know
your guests started talking about sexual
identity
uh and what have you and um
also started go to go towards the border
i'm not saying that these aren't
real issues but i don't think they're
ones of major import
for most of us a couple of thousand kids
at the border is certainly
uh a serious situation but it's not
one that's changing our lives lgbtq
issues where uh you know uh our
our men getting involved in women's
sports or
are women you know using the wrong
bathroom now that they change their
sexual identity those things that
generally don't impact
us on a daily basis and my point is that
these issues are being brought out to
kind of
get people to act if people on the right
to act with some one of a cognitive
dissonance
and acting against their own best
interests
you know serious issues in this country
uh
like uh of climate change the way we
respond to the pandemic
uh and not trusting uh science
uh the insurrection at the capitol
and and what that really means you know
in terms of uh
maintaining our democracy okay uh
mitchell we'll leave it there we'll let
our guests respond to it
you know i think that mitchell sounds a
lot like the
putatively republican governor of
arkansas on television last night where
he says
we need to stop talking about these
issues like you know immigration or the
enforcement of
our national border or whether grown men
should be able to follow little girls
into the changing room at the public
pool
we need to talk about things that people
actually care about like marginal tax
rates well
i have to tell you not only do i not
wake up in a cold sweat in the middle of
the night thinking about
marginal tax rates i don't think anybody
else does either
but these these egghead technocratic
considerations
that that people would rather us focus
on
carry with them a lot of political
premises i think that what
what mitchell is implying here is that
look we've already
solved all the the basic uh social
questions and political questions
so now we're just trying to make trade a
little bit more efficient you know we're
just trying to
get that gdp up just a little bit more
and okay it's yeah we're pumping kids
full of hormone blockers and destroying
their biochemistry
but look come on that's just progress
that's just going to happen we just have
to trust the science
because the science works this is the
progressive vision of government woodrow
wilson
our most consciously progressive
president laid this
out very well in an essay called what is
progress
woodrow wilson said under the old
constitutional system of government
we lived under the laws of isaac newton
with with fixed laws of the universe
and therefore we have a fixed human
nature and we need to
have checks and balances and balance
power out and
and make deliberative decisions as a
body politic
but that's all bunk that's all over
we're now living in the age of darwin
nothing is fixed anymore we are simply
evolving toward progress
so ironically what the effect of this is
is that
everything becomes political our chicken
sandwiches are political
our sneakers are political every our
coca-cola is political
everything is political except for
politics which woodrow wilson argued
has to be outsourced to bureaucrats and
administrators
who are beyond the scope of legitimate
political debate
you see this most notably during 2020
with the rise of the exalted
dr fauci peace be upon him our great
national leader
dr fauci says look i've never had a
political view in my life
i'm just doing what works well in order
for something to work
it has to have a purpose a lawnmower
works when it cuts lawn
right you you need to know where you are
going what you want to do
and that is certainly beyond the scope
for someone like anthony fauci
or the public health apparatus but i
think i think the premise here in the
in the question or in the comment from
mitchell is that we've already decided
all that
yeah there is no fixed human nature all
those things we were talking about
earlier about whether or not body and
soul are linked or whether or not a
nation should even be able to decide who
who comes into the country and who has
the right to vote and who has the right
to access government services
look that's just not for you to decide
you puny little american people
you peasants you you don't have have the
right to your political process
we're going to outsource that to the
experts because they can run our lives
better for us
than we can run them ourselves and i i
simply can't go along with that i i
don't think that those eggheads in
washington
have much of a sense of the american way
of life
the i don't think they're particularly
philosophically sophisticated and
frankly
a lot of the time i don't think they
have my best interests at heart so i
would prefer for
we the people of the united states of
america to exercise
the political authority that was given
to us in the constitution
that a lot of people want to take away
so here let's hear from brick new jersey
kevin republican line go ahead
uh good morning senior coffee coffee
i'm a huge fan of yours michael um been
a long time
viewer and uh i'm a daily wire
subscriber um
as a young conservative um what do you
think
how do you think we can take back the
our media
and academia i think those are the two
biggest problems right now
in um for our country um
i'm you know i'm just don't know how we
can do that
do you recommend conservatives go into
teaching
and media um do you recommend they try
to apply to cnn
or work for harvard go to harvard to
teach there or do you think we should
start our own
our own colleges and media
i would not be so much of a sadist as to
suggest that you should work for cnn or
harvard or something like that
but it's a very important question and
it's actually something i detail
at great length in my upcoming book
speechless
the left focuses on the media
certainly and especially on academia
this is where you saw the rise of
political correctness
much earlier than you saw it in other
parts of the culture and
and why is this it's because
this is how you take a hold of the
common sense you know
gramsci that that radical theorist he he
understood that the reason that a
marxist revolution did not succeed
is that the allegedly oppressed classes
the proletariat
didn't feel all that oppressed they you
know that the radicals had their
their theories but the common people
didn't really like those theories very
much
and so the the left undertook a
sophisticated and
well thought out plan to take over
academia and to take over
systems of mass communication and
they've done it rather effectively
so we're starting from a real
disadvantage here
and now how do we do this for a long
time you've heard conservatives say
like andrew breitbart said politics is
downstream of culture therefore forget
about the political questions we've just
got to go out there and
make good stuff and make good podcasts
and make our own companies i think
that's very important i think absolutely
we should do that
obviously that is that is what i do for
a living so i i think that's
a very important side of it we also need
to wield political power
we also need to and you're seeing some
republicans waking up to this you're
seeing ron desantis
waking up to this mitch mcconnell even
is waking up to this saying that we
can't just let woke corporations
and allegedly private industries
completely undermine our culture
the reason that conservatives have
become allergic to wielding the
political power that the people give
them under the constitution
over the last i don't know 20 or 30
years is because they've fallen for a
trap
that the radical left through political
correctness
leaves for them and the trap is this
political correctness
is designed to undermine traditional
standards it is a purely negative
campaign
it engages in what what marx would call
the ruthless criticism of all that
exists
from that you saw the academic movement
of critical theory and its
recent derivations that are very much in
the news like a critical race theory
it's just out to destroy the old order
and conservatives traditionally
react in one of two ways you have the
squishes who just go along with it and
they say okay well you're gonna
pump kids full of cross-sex hormones
yeah that's fine you know we want to
broaden the party after all
like the governor of arkansas but then
even the
more ornery obstinate conservatives will
come out and they'll say look i'm not
going to go along with political
correctness
because i'm a free speech absolutist
or i'm a free market absolutist or some
other kind of
absolutism that only exists in the air
and has never existed
in the actual political tradition of the
united states
and as a result of that they will eschew
standards all together
the the irony here is that either way
you do it either if you give in to the
left's new
standard or you issue standards
altogether
either way the left gets what it wants
namely the obliteration of the old
standard so i think
yes as a shorter answer to your question
it's very important for conservatives to
go into teaching it's very important for
conservatives to go into media
but that is not sufficient we also need
to recognize
that these entities exist within a
broader political
landscape a broader political framework
and we need to be
willing we need to have the courage to
wield that political power when we have
it
you know president trump i hope he lives
a long life
and then i hope when he goes to his
eternal reward he donates his body to
science and his spine
to the gop because if they would only
have courage which is
the prerequisite for all the other
virtues i think that that we could
tackle this problem much more
effectively it's much too early but i'm
sure you'll be asked or have been asked
about if president trump should run
again for another term of president
it is much too early i would agree i'm
not sure i'm a supporter of president
trump
i think he he was a tremendous president
best president of my lifetime
however he himself has said that
republicans have a deep
bench of good candidates so to me
especially if it's president trump
making that comment
that would signal that he's probably not
going to run i'm not sure
but there are there are a lot of great
candidates out there
i'm partial certainly to senator ted
cruz
with whom i host a podcast and i have
encouraged him
to run i think obviously ron desantis in
florida looks like he is eyeing a run
and he's doing a very good job
you've got other governors and senators
around the country
who seem to be interested in it so i'll
take president trump at his word i think
if there is a deep bench he could
probably play a very significant role
in determining who is going to get that
nomination and he may end up
running himself he obviously still has a
ton
of political support but i just you know
if you were to think in 2013
who will the republican nominee be i
think very few people would have said
donald trump will be the nominee and so
it's simply too early at this point
we're all just sort of wish casting i
think uh here's michael in new york in
syracuse
democrats line good morning
i'd like to say that uh dick donald is
the worst thing that happens in this
country
and you are ignorant for thinking that
any
any other way goodbye
you know i have to tell you that was not
the most persuasive argument i've heard
but it is among the more articulate
arguments that i've heard from the left
i suppose though
that i am damning with faint praise you
spend a lot of time on college campuses
talking about these kind of issues what
responses do you get because i
understand that you were hit by a water
gun at one of these events
yeah i was it wasn't i don't know what
was in that water gun
it was not water fortunately it wasn't
any any particularly noxious substance
uh so the the only casualty of the day
was my blazer
but it's funny i have a speaking tour
before covid we
spoke at 10 20 schools every year around
the country
and i i called it the men are not women
and
other uncomfortable truths tour it's
it's actually the reason that i answered
your question earlier as to what what is
one of the most controversial issues you
know that has deep philosophical
premises
believe it or not it's the idea that men
are not women i i gave other speeches on
this tour i said
babies are people i said that
cancel culture is bad i don't know i
sort of various truths
and the one that really got everybody
was that men are not women and so i
walked into this room it was at the
university of missouri kansas city
and immediately i don't know a third of
the audience were these
eccentric looking uh young activists
and they started screaming at me at the
top of their lungs you couldn't really
hear it
on the on the video feed because my
microphone was feeding directly into the
camera but in the room you really
couldn't hear the speech
so i went on undeterred i had prepared
my speech anyway so
even with with what they were screaming
i could still continue to read it
then eventually they tuckered themselves
out and they went to leave
and one of them went behind the podium
opened up a fire door
and some mass clad lunatic comes in and
sprays me with
some sort of chemicals and the police
did a great job of taking that guy down
he seemed shocked that he would face any
consequences
for his actions and then eventually
everyone was led out of the room and
what's
really bizarre is that the following day
the chancellor of the university
wrote a letter apologizing not to me but
to the students
that i was invited in the first place
and suggesting that
the idea that men are not women is not a
value of the university and it was
really
through the looking glass i really felt
as though i was in in wonderland
at that point but that is the the usual
response i get i
there have been a handful of times on
these campuses that there have been
really thoughtful
leftist responses which i love i mean
you know that's that's what i wrote my
recent book on is
thoughtful leftists and taking their
ideas seriously but but unfortunately
you don't get a lot of that and i think
part of the reason why the conservatives
on campus tend to be
much more thoughtful and articulate than
the leftists
is a circumstantial matter which is that
if you're a conservative on campus
the culture is completely against you
you are constantly having to
defend your beliefs think through your
beliefs perhaps discard some of your
beliefs
maybe deepen others whereas if you are
in the left these days your ideas are
rarely challenged they're not challenged
at work they're not challenged at school
they're not challenged in in the broader
culture and they're certainly not
challenged
in the political realm so so you know i
just think they're they're at a real
disadvantage here and
if there are intellectual and thoughtful
and articulate leftists i've got
speeches coming up this year so i look
forward to seeing you on campus
please don't ruin any more of my blazers
uh this is michael knowles of the
michael knowles show on the daily wire
it's part of our political podcast
series
this week maria in west westville new
jersey independent line hi
good morning pedro uh your guest has a
very elegant
mind and i appreciate that but i'd like
to get back to something else he said i
think it was jefferson who said
eventually our country will be saved by
the people
and i feel that we can't wait for all
these elections
where most of our uh government uh our
foreign agents to be honest with you
is there a way to have petitions to
really recall most of them right now
and the second point i wanted to make is
uh
there's an 11 trillion dollar shortfall
at the pentagon which has not been
accounted for
nobody's auditing them we're in secret
wars
all over the world so and we're with
five eyes which gives britain
and the commonwealth and israel all our
secrets so
i think um it's nice to talk about
porter versus border but i think now it
ought to be
citizens of the united states against
the globalist and i think that the
battle has to start in earnest snail
and i'd like his opinion thank you
maria those are a bunch of great
questions and comments
you know what a lot of people are going
to say when they listen to you is
they're going to say
maria this is these are crazy conspiracy
theories that you're talking about
there is no way that a foreign spy could
ever
influence the u.s government and of
course you might point them to alger
hiss a top-ranking state department
official who was working for the soviet
union during the cold war this was
detailed in whitaker chambers excellent
book witness
which which was one of the books that
moved ronald reagan from the liberal
camp to the conservative camp
you mentioned that the bureaucracy seems
to be unaccountable to the american
people this is obviously the case
this i remember antonin scalia had the
privilege of meeting him a couple times
before he died
he said that the greatest threat to
liberty in the united states is the
administrative state
because it has had such a mission drift
it has become so unaccountable as well
to the american people so
you know the degree to which these
issues are affecting our day-to-day
might be disputed but certainly there
there are a lot of problems here
you mentioned these these wars that we
seem to seem to crop up all the time
i remember the old joke in 2008 was they
told me if i voted for john mccain we'd
start another war in the middle east and
they were right i voted for john mccain
and we started more wars in the middle
east so
these problems are really frustrating um
however the way that i think
that the conservative way that one would
begin to address them
and frankly the way that the left has
addressed them to great effect
is uh through evolution not revolution i
don't think that we need to go kick the
doors in
at some administrative agency and say
you're all fired you all need to get out
of here
one it wouldn't work and at two it
probably wouldn't uh
wouldn't have much of the political
effect that you're hoping for what you
need to do
is uh have incremental change so you
need to
be able to identify the republican
office holders who are not
fulfilling their campaign promises who
are not pursuing a particularly
conservative
policy and you need to get them out
through the old-fashioned electoral
process
then when we have political power you
need to wield that power
to fire a lot of bureaucrats who are
undermining the administration
i'm not saying this is easy president
trump
faced a lot of pushback at this i mean
you consider just one department in the
government the department of homeland
security
i think the department of homeland
security alone has upwards of quarter
million employees
so that this is a huge problem and and
one or two elected officials
are not really going to change that but
but it's why you need that steady
steady incremental change the left for
the last 100 years as i
as i detail in the book speechless for a
hundred years
they amassed that sort of power and
it reminds me of ernest hemingway's
description of
going bankrupt in the sun also rises
question is how do you go bankrupt and
the answer is
gradually then suddenly and i i think
the left is amassed power in this
country
gradually and then they they exercise it
rather suddenly that's what's happening
right now and i think conservatives
would do well to learn a lesson from
that
strategy uh from east syracuse new york
ellie democrats line good morning
good morning yes mr knowles
i find you offensive your pompous way
the conservative party has done nothing
for america but divide us
and your book i probably would purchase
it
to read it i don't agree with anything
you're saying
check out history i am a history buff
and i read history and i was an
independent
all of my life until 2000 2008
and i realized that i sided more with
some of the ideas of the democrats
you have conservatives what about the
conservative movement in 1953
pushing religion right did you see the
the documentary the family
how they i i haven't seen that
documentary
well i think you should watch it because
it's very telling
and it tells you all about how a certain
set of republicans conservative
religious
which is in the constitution no laws
written
okay freedom means freedom to practice
your religion that way you want if you
want
freedom means if you are a lesbian
a gay lpgq whatever you call that's your
right
right uh
okay okay hold on ellie will let her
just respond
uh so all interesting points i
appreciate your willingness to buy and
read my book even if you
suspect that you won't agree with it um
to your point on religion you say that
the
the united states does not have any
religious underpinning and you should be
free to have whatever religion you want
let's not forget
religion factors into the declaration of
independence the declaration of
independence the entire american
revolution
is premised on the idea that there is a
god
our creator who endows us with certain
unalienable rights
so that idea which is a very christian
idea
is the basis the the philosophical basis
of the entire country
and if you were to posit a religious
view that would undermine that religious
basis
that would seem rather incoherent beyond
that
all governments all regimes have some
kind of religious basis this is
inevitable
at the ratification of the constitution
by the way this is very misunderstood
but the first amendment is ratified
there's no established church at the
national level
one of the reasons for that is that
there were many established churches at
the state level
and those those church establishments at
the state level persisted
for decades after the ratification of
the constitution we have a state
religion now the the state religion now
is secular progressivism
we are now being told that it is
unacceptable in this
culture to question the idea that a man
can become a woman
well that is enshrining in our law
the the gnostic religious idea of
dualism that that our bodies and our
souls have nothing to do with one
another
and we really are our souls as we
discussed earlier in the show
to quote the great uh political
philosopher bob dylan
everybody's got to serve somebody there
there's no question about that and then
you raise this point on freedom and
liberty which i think is so
important because it's misunderstood not
only on the left but it's misunderstood
on the right as well
there are two conceptions of liberty
here there is the modern
call it liberal idea of liberty which is
that liberty is the ability to do
whatever you want at any time and to
pursue your own desires
whatever they may be and this is an idea
that's held by the left but but by a
huge portion of the right as well
then there is the classical idea of
liberty the idea of liberty held by our
founding fathers
held by christianity held by the
pre-christian philosophers
and that idea is that liberty is not the
the ability to do whatever you want at
any time
but it is the freedom to do what you
ought to do
so just to bring that down to earth what
that means is
according to the modern idea of liberty
the heroin addict is the most
free person in the world because no
one's especially in states where that
drug is legal because that person is not
being told he can't do something if he
has the desire to shoot up heroin
why gosh darn it he's going to do it and
as long as he's got a couple bucks in
his pocket
gosh could you imagine a person any more
free
of course we all know that guy is not
free at all he's a slave
he's a slave to his base passions and
his appetites
and his sin this is why in the
traditional understanding of liberty
as christ says himself the man who sins
is a slave to sin in the
pre-christian philosophical greek
understanding of liberty
the the way that we become free is by
practicing the virtues by
cultivating our minds and disciplining
our wills this is the purpose of
liberal education the idea of liberal
education is that
we will come to make sense of our
liberty of our freedom
and be able to exercise it so that we
can tamp down those base passions that
we don't want to follow that compromise
our
our will and our intellect and be able
to pursue these higher things this is
what the founding fathers knew this is
why they wrote at great length
and i detail this at great length in my
book speechless about the difference
between liberty
and licentiousness it in the modern era
in the modern age today
the left and the right both seem to
think that liberty and licentiousness
are the same thing what our founding
fathers knew and what
wise people throughout history have
known is that liberty and licentiousness
are actually polar opposites
that licentiousness totally undermines
liberty
it's uh it's what you're seeing around
us right now and it reminds us of john
adams's
warning that our constitution our
republic is built for moral and
religious people and it's unfit
to the governance of any other sort of
people this is not just some
sunday school scolding that he's giving
us he's just he's telling us a fact
about liberty if we can't tamp down our
base passions we are not going to be
able to govern ourselves
mr knowles there's a viewer who writes
in about the transgender topic and
writes this say i am a quote leftist who
believes that transgender issues are
personal medical procedures and are as
much my business as a person who
receives a kidney transplant
i just don't need or want to have power
in someone else's medical procedures
sure well it's funny very often the
people who tell us that we need to stay
out of their medical procedures
are also calling for greater government
influence
in the medical industry in our health
care decisions
people who support socialized medicine
for instance
but of course this is not the case and i
think
republicans are are as guilty of of this
misunderstanding
as the left is this idea
that politics is this really really
narrow realm
and that the private sphere is it should
be totally opened
on the right they want to pretend that
that
politics has nothing to do with how the
economy should work so we should have
just a totally free market and i should
be able to trade whatever i want and
build whatever i want on the left they
take this
idea and they apply it to the social
realm so i should be able to sleep with
whoever i want i should be able to
mutilate my body however i like and
politics has nothing to say about this
but of course politics has quite a lot
to say about this at the very
most basic level our political
institutions should be able to protect
people
should be able to protect vulnerable
people should be able to protect the
most vulnerable people like children
and so if a political regime says you
are not permitted to mutilate children
and chemically castrate them
that is going to be one kind of polity
and if the political regime says
you have a right to chemically castrate
children if they give their consent
which is a dubious concept in itself
because children are not able to give
informed consent that's why we have age
of consent laws that say that children
are not
permitted to engage in certain behaviors
below the age of 17 or 18.
those are very different polities and we
can pretend that those are questions
that that we should ignore or push to
the side but indecision
is a certain kind of decision here it
creates what you might call the
permissive
society with horrible effects uh for
well
horrible effects for constitutional
government and also for these kids who
are being
mutilated because of the fashionable
ideologies
of radicals uh from new york republican
line samuel you are next
um hi uh first of all i say i like to
say a big fan and i think it's really
cool when i'm
talking talk that i'm talking on the
line too but besides that uh
i like to ask the question about like in
terms of the culture it's like i think
about a lot
it's like we used to have there used to
be like slavery jim crow
and then but then this changed caller
caller i'm gonna have to pause you
could you step back a little bit from
your phone only because you're becoming
muddled can you try again
uh yeah um i'd just like to ask a
question about like
in terms of like culture like you know
we used to have a lot of
uh bad moral systems you used to have
slavery you just have all these
things and then the culture changed the
large change like
there's no real opposition to it that's
significant and everyone agrees on
it and i was just wondering if
if you if you think there really will be
a day where where that becomes the case
for
say the whole transgender fight with
stopping these kids like what they're
trying to do in arkansas and
i said about abortion because i really
gone through the day
where that happens okay we'll stop you
there only because you come model but mr
knowles if you want to take anything
from that go ahead
that's a great question and an even
greater compliment i thank you for that
for the compliment at the top of that
question what you're pointing out is
that in the past
things used to be bad but now in the
present things seem to be better
and this is of course true in certain
issues but in other issues this is not
true
so that notably we no longer have legal
slavery in the united states
that's great good totally for that uh
unfortunately we kill a million babies a
year through abortion
well that's bad you know so we so some
things got better some things got worse
what the progressives will tell you is
that the arc of history is long but it
bends toward justice and things are
always getting better
and the past is always worse and the
present is always a crisis and the
future is always going to be terrific
this is in part why the left always
needs to tear down the statues
even statues of people they once liked
because because the past is always bad
and we here in the present who are
standing on the shoulders of giants
think that we're flying
and this is urgent and it's a crisis and
it's why we've got to get into that
utopian future
and the utopian future is utopian
precisely because it doesn't exist
that progressive view of history is not
going to get anywhere
now i think sometimes conservative
criticisms of the progressive view of
history
are a little bit dishonest i myself am a
catholic i have
in a certain sense a progressive view of
history i think that uh
to quote the creed christ will come
again to judge the living and the dead
and his kingdom will have no end so you
know isn't that i guess that's kind of a
progressive view of history right
but it's a little bit different than the
one that is espoused by people on the
left
namely i think things are going to get a
little bit worse in in the meantime
there's a great line a priest friend of
mine uses he says that the difference
between
a scottish optimist and a scottish
pessimist is a scottish
pessimist says things can't get any
worse and the scottish optimist says
oh yes they can and i think that the
same might be said of conservatives
as well so yes i think that in some ways
issues may get better like like slavery
and i think in in some ways issues might
get worse like abortion i hope
notably that abortion issue does get
better and people realize the absolute
moral horror
of what we as a society are doing but i
do not hold out a utopian hope that it's
all going to be kumbaya
and the big rock candy mountain anytime
in in the near future i think
we should have political humility we
should improve what we can improve
with deference to the tradition that
we've inherited
but i i don't think that we should
should hold out hope for any utopia on
earth it just ain't going to happen
uh michael knowles joining us uh for
this conversation
at the michael knowles show the michael
knowles.com is the website
that you can find it on how often do you
uh produce a podcast and what other
things do you do as aside from the
podcast well i will correct you just
slightly because
there's a there's a writer and an actor
i think who has michael knowles.com and
he never forwards me my emails but you
can find all my stuff
at michael j knowles.com correct
nothing not at all just i just don't
want his inbox to be flooded
uh uh so you can find there my show at
the daily wire you can subscribe to the
daily wire to watch the michael knowles
show
goes up five days a week you can watch
my show the book club at prageru
um you can watch my show with senator
ted cruz verdict with ted cruz
you can order my new book speechless
controlling words controlling minds you
can order my previous blank book
reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guide
and so you can find all that stuff at
links for all that at michael j
knowles dot com and uh you you can also
please do write in
social media in the mail bag because i
was so pleased to be able to come on
this show today because i do
love speaking to callers all around the
country so i really appreciate that
opportunity mr knowles thanks for your
time today
thank you